what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel
um today we are going to be talking
about some Andrew Tate updates as you
guys may or may not know I was one of
the last people that interviewed um Tate
before
um his arrest and you know I'm sure
everyone knows this but I'm just gonna
keep people up to speed in case you
don't
um Tate basically has been arrested for
months um without being charged with a
crime so they've essentially insinuated
that he's done
um you know that he's been trafficking
girls and then they come out with some
footage showing those girls luxury
shopping I don't know what kind of human
trafficking that is
but that is besides the point right so
basically they've in my opinion right
falsely accused him of something looking
for evidence for months nothing nothing
nothing we find out
um I don't know a week or two ago that
he's let out of prison right or out of
jail and now he's on house arrest
however
um when he's let out
we're gonna give them the update
blessing we put a pull up the footage
so they said Andrew Tate got poisoned
now I'm reacting to this video because I
think they the tweets are gone did The
Matrix get the tweets
The Matrix got the tweets so I know I
know okay so let's let's take get our
give our take blessing all right guys
now this is actually very very
concerning so recently Andrew take
repeated out saying face swollen blood
pressure is through the roof Skin's on
fire hard to breathe some sort of severe
reaction or poison only had coffee and
water so far today all appeared in the
last five minutes eyes almost chucked
Gathering she whatever that means and
these are the videos that he attached
okay
what does that look like too does that
look like
I thought when people got poisoned they
just died no no it was bad like I
watched The Twist before it got deleted
like he was breathing heavy okay let me
let's keep I think they're gonna show it
yeah let's see it's just because right
now it looks like an allergic reaction
but nah the way he was breathing yeah it
was different
it doesn't look like him anymore no
yeah
wow yeah that's not normal
oh wow
what the hell
oh if you didn't take out the sound
wow
what kind of point like I swear when I
see it poison in movies I thought they
just like died
yeah I don't know what's going on I'm
not a poison expert but then again he
said he did have some sort of cancer
thing going on with him as well so uh so
maybe the cancer caught up to him yeah
he said he had like lung cancer or
something I'm not sure I know that it's
some sort of cancer situation and he
needs medical attention uh I think his
doctors in Dubai but it's been obviously
been in right Romania for a while
right
it's crazy though like from the last
time he came here he looks way older
no he looks so different from the last
time he was here yeah because we
interviewed him like literally right
before now honestly this really looks
bad I don't even know what to say to
this it's some sort of a bad reaction to
something but as he said he's only had
water so this actually could be some
sort of poison which is really really
odd because if there's more updates to
this I'll be sure to make a video so
yeah leave a like on the video subscribe
with notifications and yeah that's it
because I want you to hear the breathing
the breathing okay well because the
other thing is too if he got poisoned
like someone would have had to have
brought it in
so then you question like hit the people
around him
like who's the
which it's crazy because he seems like
he just has the tightest oh yeah like
his his friends are so close
so
what a week later he's really sick I
mean he's like if you look at his tweets
from this one
I'm gonna go to the video
yeah
oh no the the picture
all right you can see from the picture
like this is the video of his arm
hey sounds like he's in pain bro sounds
serious bro wow
is that like a rash or something like
I hope he's okay that's crazy
it's just crazy because it's like he was
on top of the world do you know what I
mean like everything was going right for
him like literally he was killing like
he was everywhere he's going viral on
every platform and it was like they kept
trying to take him down on every social
media platform and he's still
everywhere and it was like they took him
down and everything then he comes on our
show goes crazy viral bananas and now
it's like
he then he gets arrested and they throw
out all of these accusations at him and
he beats all of them really I feel like
they keep changing the rules for him as
well like he was supposed to be detained
for 30 days they extended after three
months now they put him under house
arrest they keep extending it it's like
we're gonna put you on the look down
until we find something on you like it's
crazy
well and it also shows like he must have
lived a pretty clean life when you think
about it because you go into most people
that deep you'll find something they're
still trying to look look me down for
six months you know I mean you find
something on me yeah
and yeah it's just crazy because you
know
Matrix attacks and it just sounds like a
conspiracy theory on the outside looking
in but it's like all this stuff it's
nuts that it's happening to him
now it's definitely not a conspiracy
like if you actually observe what's
going on with Andrews like
yeah
anyone can get get humbled yeah
no and I think what I realized the other
day was you know I've had everyone so
mad at me I won't say why
um but what I realized is people really
get angry when you start to have more
influence than them like more so I think
than money people get mad about
influence and I think that's what Andrew
did was he just had so much like who has
more influenced than Andrew Tate
yeah right now among young boys like I
don't know anyone any I know really I
don't say no one really yeah and that's
like to me that's the most who does more
in society the next generation of men so
he has more influence over the next
generation of men than you know the
powers that be and I think they don't
like that
yeah definitely as we can see right now
let me let's see through I want to check
the chat a lot of reaction in his skin
or something
bruh
look it's good you can see like there's
a like there's a proper rash on his skin
bro like that's
right and actually did it between says
what they deleted the tweets and stuff
like that like even when he was still up
like couldn't see the comments or
anything like that like all right crazy
wow
pain bro eat bro he's fighting to
breathe bro
matter that's not a joke bro that is not
a joke this isn't a minor situation
like it breathing bro like you know how
would they have gotten like I'm like
thinking all he had was water and coffee
Nah if they want to get to you they'll
get to you I wonder if they could like
poison the water in your hat but then
everyone would have to get it so it'd
have to be someone that's in there
yeah I mean stuff like this it's usually
an inside job in it right if you think
about it
it's usually someone is not happy
someone who started probably on his
level I don't know what's going on over
there but
yeah it can happen
it's not out of the question really
sorry we're laughing Inside Job
um yeah I mean that does happen to
people sometimes you know it's like
there's two people and one gets a lot
more influence and success
yeah something like that and then
you know some people make videos but
others
they might try to kill you yeah yeah
yeah
it just you know shows the level of
enemies that he has yeah
um
damn are we I wish him well you know
yeah I really
he was a great guy when he was here no
he was so nice and that's the other
thing like they always were trying to
make him out to be like people I've had
so many people ask me like how he was
I'm like he was perfectly polite I mean
he wasn't here like he was in and out
pretty quick but
yeah but like he was no I see why
yeah no and that's the other thing he
was so about like we wanted to do the
show live and he didn't want to do it
live because of security reasons and
even exactly was paranoid until I
started to see you know yeah like he
can't because he came in with the two he
had the guys he had these huge guards
like huge oh my gosh he just guys we
have a seat
yeah it made me want some I'm like let
me get some guards
um but
yeah and
yeah and I was like wow he's bringing
these guards for a podcast
but
like if you have trouble breathing bruh
that is life that's that's Survival Mode
like you know what I'm saying it's not
just all I'm feeling a little bit of
pain do you get what I'm saying this is
survival mode right now
oh did you hear they're trying to put a
charge on Tristan as well like
um some inciting violence charge
how do you incite violence
crazy
three months he looked these guys up he
couldn't find nothing
put them under house arrest now you try
and find something like I don't think to
be honest I don't think I don't think
Andrew is gonna be it's gonna be free to
be honest really you don't I don't think
so
I want it to be free I just yeah but I
don't think it's gonna be free I think
they're just gonna have to find
something because
if you keep someone like it's almost
like five months now locked up
it's embarrassing as well to let him go
um
because then people are gonna have to
really like
you know because it proves his point so
you're gonna have to take him down you
know they've gone too far already
no I I have a feeling he'll get out
guys like that always figure out a way
out of it
um
but it does show that like
I think I used to think our justice
system was a lot more fair than it seems
to be because if you if you piss off the
wrong people it doesn't really seem to
matter where you are in the world
they'll come get you come get you yeah
um is it not an American citizen like
how come the warehouse does not say
anything on this case I don't think he's
an American citizen he has to be I
thought he was born in the UK
no he was I think it was was he born in
here I think it was born in America I
read the channel now let's see where was
Tate born where was tapeworm chat well
it has to be at least American I think
he would have gone into because his dad
was American so I think it would have
gone maybe and got naturalized or
something
I really don't think he's America I
think he's born in England
yeah but his dad is American
I was born in America yeah he's American
I wonder why like the well it's Biden
yeah but the White House says to say
something like it's an American citizen
down there
oh yeah you would think you think yeah
but but I think they're not going to
because it's too like the government's
too left
so because of that because of that like
it this goes into feminism because
they're going to take the women's side
and say oh maybe he did it you know even
though the craziest part to me was when
they were luxury shopping I'm sorry if
you if you had a website open that could
say
oh sign up to be you know trafficked in
luxury you know how many girls would
sign up for that
yeah no I'm not saying you did though
that traffic and stuff still I'm not
saying that I don't think it did no
that's what I'm saying it wasn't
trafficking these girls were voluntarily
there
very obviously but
yeah but I don't know why the warehouse
is not saying something on this one
because is there no something in the
Constitution that says that they have to
for an American citizen
they have done they've done that for
Worse people like that Britney check
yeah they went and traded her for an
arms dealer
like damn
someone said I looked pregnant in the
chat rude
sorry blessing told me to stop reading
the comments
I'll continue
he said his Skin's on fire go back to
his face the way it showed his face
no not the video
no he looks completely different
yes is it just me
yeah he or does he look different bro
like bro yeah like literally he's aged
like 10 years
when it came to this studio
Man look he did not look like that right
he didn't look like that bro it's a
shame well I know obviously people say
yeah but but he's got the beard and that
yeah but still
bruh like his face is this part of his
face bruh this part
that looks like he just just 10 years
just got added on bro just got added
well like times two now that's crazy bro
can you even imagine like even the
stress of everyone thinking like you go
down the street and you ask people about
Andrew if it's not the young guys that
like the hatred is so crazy the visceral
reaction people get to Andrew Tate and
it's crazy how well he seemed to handle
it before
yeah but I said programming because if
you actually ask someone why do you hate
Andrew they don't know yeah there's one
one lady that came on the panel
and and someone actually asked like
uh why why do you hate Andrew like they
had already made like their decision
like we don't like him
I think many people just want him to be
arrested not even for this they just
don't like him
[Music]
which is crazy
yeah and it's crazy how people will
paint like if you view the world a
certain way like you'll paint someone
out to be a certain way
because you know and it's just because
they view Andrew that way that they're
going to paint him out to be that way
yeah I'll work for his mentor as well
you know like the stress
the opinions of people
just yeah it's crazy it's got to be a
lot and he's a really he's clearly a
mentally strong dude you know but I mean
everyone he's still human yeah that'll
break down anybody
bruh that's that's scary bro I don't
know can you can you see the comments
underneath this one though that's it see
that's what I'm saying I couldn't even
see the comments there
oh
it's not in the loud it's not even
allowing us to see the comments but at
the end of the day we're like again in
my opinion it's not wild
to believe that
what
I should delete it as you guys were
doing it earlier yeah
what the heck
literally while we're alive crazy wow
well I think so what do you think you
think it's the cancer catching up to him
or you think it's the Matrix
to be honest it could be it could be
both or an allergic reaction it could be
both I'm just not sure like what what
the conditions of his house arrest are
because house arrest seems fun but
you're still under arrest so I don't
know and who's in and out of his house
yeah can you cook food freely do you get
food still delivered to you you get your
leg I don't know the conditions you know
there has to be some sort of limitations
so they could be trying to get I think
they are trying to game it's too much of
a big influence there I think it's too
much of like a coincidence it just seems
like something's up
yeah I would be surprised if something
was just you know
because when it came on the show he did
what 60 000 people live 60k yeah that's
crazy that was
that was it was crazy I think I barely
talked that panel because it was so like
gosh there's so many big personalities
on it but but that's like the most I've
ever been recognized ever like that's
the most attention the channel ever
gotten and
the crazy thing is they tried to stifle
it that video too because they
demonetized it and age restricted it
like within a day
yeah I wanted to do a live type one in
the chat if you want to see a life of
Andrew T again yeah yeah blessing wants
to re like edit out the commercials and
maybe add in a couple yeah
you know what we could do I just had an
idea so have
me react to the original Andrew Tate
thing and say what I was thinking and
then we could edit in the auntie's
reaction and edit him what she was
thinking during it you can do it live no
no oh like with Auntie like were we both
yeah just do like life
like life you can even bring back to
nalva you know who is not invited
you know what we should do as well we
should get uh Justin
if Justin comes oh yeah yeah we'll do
like a live reaction with Justin as well
into the the tape panel
[Music]
I think that would be dope her should be
so long we'd have to like there's a lot
of ones going on with the child we've
done a 24-hour stream before I think
we'll be okay yeah I'm just thinking
okay you have to mentally prepare
everyone coming that you will be here
for a long time it's an afternoon guys
it's gonna be but I think it'd be crazy
people would like to see that I might
even get like causes or maybe bringing
his friends over Zoom yeah so like you
know we do like a tate day
yeah I know that's a good idea yeah now
and we could
and because I always think it's
interesting to see what people were
thinking behind videos and I was
thinking
I'm not gonna say her name
huh but there's a certain person
that I really questioned if I should
have brought you know what's funny about
that panel I was really nervous that it
was like the I I was so nervous about
picking the right people to put on it
and I thought I did a bad job at the end
but let me tell you
I think that's like the one of the most
I think that's the most viewed panel in
the manosphere
yeah I would like to see you do a
one-on-one interview with Tate though
yeah I want to I don't know I think that
would be amazing
yeah
I mean I hope he gets at this point we
don't even know if he's getting out you
know I hope he's okay if they're
deleting the tweets you know
yeah something okay so if the Matrix
attacked him and now he's tweeting about
it what do you think the Matrix would
like come at him harder or back off
because he told people
um now I think at this point they're
just gonna they're trying to delay him
so they don't care uh so you think yeah
at all costs they're gonna
yeah it's just gonna be a day where you
just hear that something happened to
Andrew
that's crazy like that but the sad thing
is like we don't know
who are behind the scenes so there's no
one you can even go like you know what I
mean because there's no one point to and
say oh they did it or they did it yeah
but it's fighting a system though right
it's difficult like there's no like a
person who's like the number one you
know I mean they're not showing their
faces yeah that's what I was gonna say I
think there are I just think you don't
see them
yeah I'll say the government is a part
of it
clearly because they're not saying
anything
they have to know what's going on I
don't even think about the government
wasn't saying anything
yeah like I've never a head of a place
you know what they used to always tell
me because me I'm from Africa or
whatever
like if you're a U.S citizen if you go
somewhere in this world or or you get
taken hostage
the government is going to come and get
you
so people don't tend to kidnap American
or British people or something because
the government's gonna come and get them
but for Tate silence right that's so
true which is crazy to me
because I'm like for U.S citizen not to
get like I thought you guys are all free
speech and I thought you guys are all
Justice in that but
it was the stand man
and the other thing is blatant
corruption doesn't go
unchecked anymore
I I mean even in the U.S there's a big
portion of people that believe that the
last election was stolen
but there's no one to be mad at there's
no one you can point and that's a
problem when you're fighting against the
system is you don't know who the people
are behind the system
and so it makes it harder because you
can't even when we talk about the Matrix
who is the Matrix and they have ideas
right like they think the gates are in
it or all these like big Elite like
there's people that they say are in it
but who do you get mad at you actually
never know like even in the movie The
Matrix was that guy that you know I mean
it's just a face
you can put a face to it but you you
don't want to know the people really who
are behind it what what's the machine is
that yeah
but they're definitely out to get him he
is exposing a lot
is too much influence I feel like if you
have influence regardless you're a
Target
because they either want to control you
and if they don't want to control you
they're going to delete you it can
happen with everyone who's ever had
influence
really yeah like I remember one time
like Michael Jackson was fighting Sony
because they're so influential in the
music world to put something on him
and then that kind of killed his voice
you think about Kanye they put something
on him that killed his voice
when have you ever heard of a
billionaire come from 11 billion to just
be
pushed out a billionaire that's crazy
yeah and I think they paint Kanye I know
you think Kanye is a bit crazy no no I
don't I don't think he's crazy I think
he's gifted and I think gifted people
like I genuinely think Kanye's are gay
of course I I can't yeah I think Gay's
gifts I was talking about this in my
coffee thought I think his gifts come
from God and I think people like people
have certain gifts right that literally
come from God and I think Tate has a
gift when he talks he barely stutters
he can just talk and talk and talk and
he's one of the few people that's
entertaining educational and
inspirational yeah no who who is that
combination and I think that like God
puts us on the Earth right to
like do good and you can either use that
your powers like for good or for bad and
there's certain people that have like
super powers
being a creative I don't I think Kanye
has good intentions
but I think they drove him crazy
they can drive you crazy by what they
put on you because it's a creative as
well you're constantly working your mind
so you are in like a mind sport
and they know that and everyone who's a
creative knows this so they can really
push push you to the limits until you
break down yourself I think that's what
happened to Kanye at some point he did
break down
but I'll say that he had good intentions
he was working on himself and he's a
genius and they know it as well if he
had kept on going
he was going to do amazing things in the
world like from the music world no one
has managed to do what he did in the
fashion world and they told him he
couldn't do it like here the sneaker
that went head to head with athletes
crazy
yeah and it's crazy how everything was
like taken from him in the like that
yeah
yeah and it's crazy too because Kanye I
can't call him yay it's so hard I'm
sorry I'm sorry yeah I'm trying to be
respectful but I just but yeah
he's so gifted right and I think that
sometimes the best stories in her
culture are people that have to go
through like trials and tribulations in
order to overcome something and I think
that sometimes like God gives people
gifts knowing that they have to like
overcome certain things and it's kind of
up to them whether they can use their
gifts for good or their gifts for evil
and I think that yay in his early career
used it for evil when you think about it
like I mean come on we all know the song
you're such a huh
no but think about it like that it was
such a catchy song I'm not even I knew
all the words I'm sorry I'm sorry but
like when you think about it it's it's
what you say is what you become and it
contributes like to the evil in the
world and that's not a good message
right yeah and
the problem though is that evil sells
better like drama sells better yeah and
and sex sells better and all that stuff
just sells and so it's very tempting and
most people can't like overcome that
test because the money is too big yep
right so it's like when the money is in
front of them and you get to pick like
do you use your gift to bring like truth
to the world to spread awareness to
bring like light to make the world a
better place or do you use it for evil
and I think most people that are
extremely talented like nowadays use it
for evil or at least not good because
when you think about it all of the
entertainment industry most of those
people are crazy gifted yeah like look
at Sam Smith he's so crazy gifted and he
could have been such a powerful like
light for good in the world but he used
it for evil and I think God like gives
the people with the most like Talent the
mo like and because I don't know you
just know an exceptional person when you
meet them like you you they come into a
room and they're just like different
like something's interesting like they
just see the world in a different way
and I think that the the powers that be
don't like when they can't control
someone because if even if they're doing
something good if they can be controlled
then they're happy but if you push it
too far like Yay pushed it too far Tate
pushed it too far sneako pushed it too
far they they just try to like kill it
and then the other issue is you have
people
that don't you and this is what I
realized with the the reaction talents
and all the hit the reaction channels
all the hit pieces they don't use their
talents for good and they're mad because
they see other people using their
talents for good so they become the
biggest critics because the people that
are using their talents for good are
doing what they can't do so when you see
you know
um all these reaction channels like
picking apart all of the content
creators online that are literally doing
good when they when they see them
calling yay crazy or saying that Tate
did this it's because
those usually the reaction channels and
those content creators that are
criticizing them had the same Talent or
at least a similar they had some talent
that makes them great right but they
didn't use it for good they just used it
for like their own selfish whatever I
don't think that the talent I think they
had the ambition they had the dream but
they never went for it it's like you
want to be a musician but you know ever
go for it 50 years down the line you
watch someone who was in the same class
imagine being in the same class with
Kanye West you went through the same
high school and he just went and did
this you'll be pissed off because you'll
be like how come you must have some sort
of power because it was a time when
um the Illuminati whatever thing was
very hard pushed on and Connie was
making music which was very dark like
the Dark Twisted Fantasy the music was
very dark that's when when he was using
his Force for evil and then he turned
and started using his Force for good
right you see him in the biggest church
in America which was a Lakewood the
biggest Christian Church in America
and you see a celebrity and I don't
think anyone has ever done it at that
scale saying I'm gonna use my talent for
good my Force for good and
soon after it didn't even last like a
year
they tried to push him back into that
space again of like you have to go back
into that space again off
when I look at yay I look at him and I I
look at content as art like that's what
people always think I'm in it for like
like they always call me a grifter they
whatever and like they think I'm in it
for money but I don't look at like I
look at not all content in this art but
I think that content can be art right
and and I like to like paint a picture
of what's going on in society and like I
love to bring like together people that
push the conversation forward and I
think when yay shows what went on in
society because he's the product of a
single mother home he's the product of
somebody that was lied to like he was
lied to about the world because his mom
told him that his dad was a deadbeat and
his dad wasn't and how many men has that
happened to that's happened to so many
guys where they they think their dad's
the bad guy and you see the effects of
that going on in his life because what
what type of woman did he pick to raise
his kids he could have had anybody who
has more options than a billionaire
no seriously like then yay I mean you
might say maybe at that time he wasn't
as fan as famous but he was still yay he
could have had anyone but he picked like
the what did they say the Jezebel the
jet like The Jezebel right and it's
because like I think anyways because he
was raised like by the world yeah and
and so when he started to switch and be
a force for good it's like the force is
for evil and I'm not even saying like I
don't you know Kim has good and evil but
like she's done some good things too but
but but they can't stand to see you like
trying to be better yeah if even on the
there's one episode actually when on the
their show the Kardashian show when she
actually said I know you uh you want to
do this thing but it doesn't mean that
I'm gonna you know it's for me as well
you know I mean like when you get like
you're trying to be better but you have
that Eternal like people in your house
fighting you and there's a man as well I
think it comes to feminism he couldn't
lead he's saying my family I'm the head
of the household this is what I want my
family to be and your wife keeps
fighting you like
there's some quote that's like something
then a quarrelsome wife but something
where it's like there's some Bible quote
where it's like nothing's worse than
having a quarrelsome why yeah and I can
see his frustration as well and and
that's the thing when when you start to
like get more power influence Fame it's
like everybody comes out of the
Woodworks and I had to do that too like
when I I made a decision like you know I
drank a bit in school and I just didn't
want to after that and I had to cut off
like so many people because like they
would just always try to get me to drink
and I didn't want to anymore you have to
change the environment
yeah yeah and it's the same thing here
like you know sometimes it's hard making
female friends because they just live
this life where they go out every
weekend they're just doing like they're
doing nothing and it's like what and
it's even like where I get you know
old friends right that live a certain
way and you know they're mad that I
don't live that you know it's just
they get and that's the thing like you
can't become a better person without
sort of like cleaning your circle a bit
yeah I mean like you have to clean your
environment you know I mean it's like
there's um there's a proverb I don't
know if it's an African probe but
actually let's say is that
um
like when you start obviously like you
need people that think I like
like you can't if you have 10 friends
that are bad you're not going to
influence them
they're going to influence you so you
have to move away from that pack I know
sometimes people like you should try to
help people nah
that is the biggest lesson I've learned
I swear I've learned
you know I'm not gonna name names
[Music]
you try to help out someone they make a
video calling you uh
yeah we're not going out so so
but but no you're right though you're
right because it
it's like if you're the only one that
sees like the truth in the room or like
that is trying to do good in the world
in the room then they're going to
influence you you I doubt yeah yeah like
if you hang around people that drink
you're going to drink like there's no
way about it me at this I I didn't I
didn't know I have a single drink until
I was like 19 because I was in church
but when I was like 19 all my friends
were drinking so all this time when I
come to my birthday party you go to a
birthday party everyone is drinking
you're not gonna be the Christian guy in
in a party where everyone's drinking
because obviously you look awkward to
everyone you know what I mean so you're
gonna be like ah maybe let me just try
it right and that's how it starts
let me just try it hmm no you know it's
crazy I moved because I it's crazy how
far I've come with drinking like I never
you never see me drink no no no and
that's the thing like I used to it used
to be really hard for me to say no and
so I ended up moving I moved from um
Chicago to Milwaukee and I ended up just
like surrounding I got really involved
in the church there and I ended up just
like surrounding myself with different
people and
um it's crazy because now it's not even
hard for me to say no like I don't I
don't care but it's crazy because at one
point it was actually hard
yeah okay yeah I can imagine
once you're in the thing it's like very
hard and if you keep yourself around the
same circles it's very hard to live that
habit as well so yeah it's my advice to
anyone out there if you want to make you
know change your life change your people
yeah get friends that run up the should
we run up the stairs
yeah let's run up the stairs run up the
stairs I have to do a live stream
Direction after this so maybe maybe in
the morning I don't know maybe maybe
already lives are you live streaming
that video Yeah guys Justin Justin's
gonna be speaking on Tate soon after
this okay guys put a one in the chat a
blessing should run up 21 flights of
stairs
I'm trying to be better
I realize I want to be free so I
surrounded myself with fit people
yeah you're doing good he did two
flights he did 42 flights out two to 42
flights of stairs
that's great for you whatever I'm
putting in the chat I gotta refresh it
my internet's wonky nah they don't want
me to run up the stairs
uh damn it damn it shot
come on man
Boston excited to do the stairs with me
every day and he's been doing decent but
not as good as we were hoping
yeah
yo the chat is not giving me a message
yeah all right guys so I'm a big guy you
know I'm like 260 pounds trying to calm
down so you guys are gonna witness the
transformation happen because I've
surrounded myself with people that are
not gonna they're gonna bully me from a
whale
to a healthy dude what do you want to
how much do you want to weigh in three
months
I don't know I just want to look good
you know I don't have way goes okay how
tall are you let's look up your BMI
uh this track this has gone very off
track but what's your what's your height
your five nine uh I don't even know what
that stuff though you know okay I'll say
five two effective I mean
I mean somewhere there you know five
nine oh someone is saying two thank you
punk thank you you don't want me to run
up the steps thank you okay mail BMI
510.
so let's see what you're supposed to be
five foot
. hey Jasmine
why is it being weird
um
yeah I need all the healthy tips guys I
don't think I should start you know pill
wanted me to start a channel you know
doing this Fitness stuff how much should
you weigh at five ten if I get enough
people saying five maybe I'll do it
you're supposed to wear 174 to 208
pounds
okay let's go to 28208
okay so you want to be 60 pounds in
three months that's a lot yeah that's it
you'd have to lose like
seven pounds a week is doable but it's
just
yeah
it says 260 they said they just said no
wonder you're not on camera
effects yeah they said this is wild guys
can you bully blessing in the chat damn
it
I don't even look 260. guys what do you
what do you think no do I look 260
though yes
get me a pal
yeah man no he actually does I was
surprised he weighed that much but
um yeah but I think that's like what we
tell ourselves to not make us lose
weight
yeah and I think it's because we we do
look as heavy as we are but but listen I
want to lose weight you know I mean and
I don't think you know I'm camera ready
you know I'm not I'm not trying to
promote you know someone says love
yourself blessing I do love myself you
know to be healthy
yeah yeah what are you what what should
his goal weight be all right chat
how did this turn from being
entertainment go away I'm a woman I get
distracted really easily yeah let's get
back on topic you know what I mean okay
let's just pick three months go see me
three months what should he be at we're
gonna pick a date so and we're going to
America in this so I'm gonna bother him
the whole time oh damn I had the
American food is amazing
so July 28th July 28th
you can be skinny and eat Chick-fil-A
it's not even that bad if you order the
right stuff you just have to get the
grilled chicken someone gave me two 25.
that's reasonable right there thank you
okay 225 yeah let's go for two twin five
yeah two people two twenty five
don't need to know about my age
he's done a lot of damage for such a
young age he is Young and successful
though he does produce you know it's
like it's a double-edged sword because
you know you are you are a successful
young man you are the most talented
producer in the game yeah you sit behind
the desk a lot and eat a lot of crap
food but now I'm out here you know
improving my life yeah guys um how long
does he have to so he keeps drinking um
Sprite
pill pill
no I know but every time you say you
stop you do it again so this is you are
lying on me right now you know I mean
when's the last time you had one like
two days ago
we've had like 10 talks listen we are
now on the water wave you know
have your water guys
okay they said 21 flights three times a
day
God damn
this guy speaking has never done that
you know it's hard so anyway it's okay
guys so um guys
um
so you know in honor of Tate
if okay you know what this is a good
goal so because of Tate Tate's big
motivator big motivational blessing has
to get
on track to 225 so whatever 225 divided
by five what's that what's that how many
pounds is that a week
um 220 all right so listen it's 260
minus 225 is 35 pounds divided by 12.
that's three pounds a week so he has to
be
at three pounds losing three pounds a
week and whenever Tate gets out
if he sees you and you're still a whale
we can't we can't we can't have that
here today is gonna roast me a lot yeah
yeah and so 60 000 people yeah
and you know I I will say myself too
guys I've been trying to lose 15 pounds
for a very long time yo that's a crazy
Channel actually you know I'm actually
going to start that campaign I want to
come I want to wear a mask because some
of you guys are crazy I and I want to do
a Dewey Forte challenge I do it for Tate
challenge I want to do for tea challenge
yeah
King Richard is gonna train me in the
gym the man up there do it for tea
challenge yeah I wanna yeah and you know
I'll get in on it I'm trying to lose
this last 15 I've been trying for so
long
power me
they said it's impossible to take Wheels
seriously Pro tip put the fork down
yeah can you do 100 push-ups a day nah
I'm not there yet
yeah
they said don't look okay guys guys stop
simping you know I could lose like 10
pounds like stop it I'm not saying I got
a lot of weight to lose but 10 pounds
wouldn't kill me
like it's just soft simping we don't
simp here
go simp on someone says work for six
hours a day I'm busy making content give
up there oh they know my weakness they
said give up sugar
yeah
yeah pill it's white and brown sugar
here
are you a snitch yeah you put you
blasting me in front of a thousand
people bro yeah yeah
it's it's because I care
oh
it's because I'm actually really proud
of him he's been doing really good with
the stairs
yeah we're getting there we're gonna do
one right now
and to do the life you know I got people
waiting anyways anyways guys
um thank you for watching you know
blessing thank you for your
contributions from the best producer on
YouTube genuinely who's better than
blessing nobody no find me someone find
someone set who's better nobody
the best producer on YouTube
um like the video on your way out guys
and let me know in the comments it's in
a matrix attack what do you think is
going on with Tate is it just an
allergic reaction is cancer catching up
to him what is going on let us know in
the chat like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel